That sums up the different things
wanted to talk about in triple C.
So we talked about
coordinating between agents.
We talked about communicating
between agents.
And we talked about coaching or
kind of teaching,
instructing between agents to convey
an idea of a reward function.
So what do you think?
Are you ready to through and
kind of fill in the topics that
we touched on in each of these?
>> I'm going to say no and-
>> I don't think that's on the script.
You're supposed to say yes, and
we're supposed to go through it.
>> I'll tell you why because I
think this is really cool, and
I think we're giving it short shrift.
I think there are several more examples
that we could go through that would
really kind of drive home this point,
particularly the coaching and
communication point.
And I think we should do it.
So let's do some more of these.
>> So what you're saying is you
didn't think I lectured enough, and
that I should now on the spot
make up more material.
That's kind of tough.
>> You don't have to
make up more material.
I mean, the material is out there,
you can just very easily describe
some stuff that we know about.
How about doing that?
No?
>> [LAUGH] I'd rather not, I mean I
feel like we covered the topic and
we should just go with it.
>> Okay, I think I can prove to you
that we haven't covered the topic.
And the way I could prove it to you is
simply by covering more of the topic.
>> Okay, that's fair.
>> All right, so let's do that.
So you know what, here,
I'll make it easy for you.
I have two or three things in mind that
I think that we could talk about that
would really kind of
drive the point home, and
I will talk about them happily.
>> All right, I appreciate that,
and I would be very interested to hear
what you have to say about these topics.
So why don't we stop for now, and
then you can go research those topics,
and we'll come back and talk about it.
>> Nope,
I'm ready to talk about them now.
>> Wow, okay, that's impressive.
>> Thank you.
>> So you just want to take over.
Okay, so the thing is I'm actually
in Rhode Island right now, and
so it's not clear to me how we can just
kind of switch places and let you drive.
>> Well, why don't we use
the magic of technology?